So one of the things we can do with
strings that we can't do with numbers, is we can
extract subsequences from the strings. So remember what a string
is, is a sequence of characters. If we have a
string, we can use the square brackets to extract
parts of that string. So if we have the string
udacity, and we use the square bracket, with the value
0, that would select the zeroth character from the string.
The characters of the string are indexed starting
from 0, so the result of index 0,
is the string with just the letter u.
The expression inside the square brackets can be
anything that evaluates to a number. So we could have, 1 plus 1 in here. 1
plus 1 evaluates to the number 2. And at position 2, we find the letter a,
so the value of this would be the string containing
the single letter a. This looks a little strange and
we wouldn't normally use indexing with the string literal like
this, but it does work. It looks a lot more normal
when we're doing it with a variable. We've initialized the
variable name to the string Dave. Then when we do name
index 0, whatever the variable name is, that will give
us the first letter of that string, in this case it's
the uppercase D. Let's try that in the Python interpreter. So here, I've defined
the variable name, with the value, the string Dave. And I'm printing name index
0. I get the first letter. If I try instead, to
print name index 3, that will give us the fourth letter, the e.
Suppose I tried to do name index 4. Well, there's no character
at position 4, remember that the indexes start at 0,
so this is 0, 1, 2, 3. When I run this,
what I get is an error. I get an error
because I've asked for position 4 of the string; that's out
of range, so the error I get says that that
string index is out of range. What I can do is
use negative numbers. When I use negative numbers in my index
it starts counting from the back of the string. So name
index negative 1 will go as the last character in the string. If I do name index
negative 2, that will give us the next to last character which is the v.